you've called for some kind of
international body which I agree with
when I was running for president I
pitched a world data organization that
was pitched to me by Ian bremmer who
just had a TED Talk that I know you saw
Yeah we actually met at Ted I'll let you
finish your story but a quick anecdote
about Ian is we met at lunch the day
before I gave my TED Talk and he said
what's your Ted talk about and I said
well imagine you're at a 60s protesting
you say what do you want or what do we
want International governance for AI
when do we want it now and he interns to
me and says six months ago so an
international body
I I've called for uh something I'm not
sure if you included in your Senate
testimony which is uh an AI dedicated or
regulatory body here in the U.S what do
you think about that idea yeah I think
absolutely I mean I think there should
both be a cabinet level agency or office
and then you know an agency underneath
that there's just too much going on
right now to expect that all the
existing agencies have it covered they
kind of wrote a memo kind of saying that
in in between the lines but the reality
is that the existing laws don't
anticipate certain things like we have
laws about protecting private individual
speech but what do you do if somebody
makes a billion pieces of harmful
misinformation a day we don't have laws
for that just to give you one example AI
makes things possible in a wholesale way
where they could only be possible retail
before it's sort of similar to like a
submachine gun versus a knife you have
to think about them differently so there
are a lot of new both opportunities we
want to take advantage of and a lot of
risks that we need to look out for I
think we need somebody in the White
House whose job is full-time think about
this and nothing else and they need a
staff to keep up with all of the
different parameters of it and this is
not to like cut out existing agencies
from from the loop but we're going to
need some new things so for example I
think that we want to have something
like FDA approval if somebody's going to
do research that's one thing but if
they're going to roll out a system to a
hundred thousand people or sorry 100
million people
um you know we really want to test it
make sure it's safe in the same way we
do with a drug we don't just say I did
you know trials on 10 people okay let's
put it out to every drugstore on the
planet we say let's show that you know
this is right and we need independent
examiners to say you've made this case
but there are weaknesses in your case we
need to understand this better you say
that there's this risk you don't have
anything about the risk we also need an
agency to push the companies to be
transparent you have Microsoft saying
transparency is important to us and then
they use gpt4 and we don't know what's
inside of gpt4 we don't know what it's
trained on which has a huge influence on
things like bias so we need someone to
really hold the company's feet to the
fire so I am a hundred percent for
having an agency like that and I've been
talking to people in Washington and
trying to talk that idea as much as I
can yeah so after you went uh to the
Senate your testimony was very warmly
received what do you see as the
prospects for some of your
recommendations being followed or
a coherent regulatory approach yeah I
like the word coherent that is that is
the the nub of it um on the one hand I'm
very inspired in certain ways so the
hearings that I was at hearing
um was one of the most bipartisan things
I think the Senate has done in a long
time and I think everyone I know who
kind of follows Washington more closely
than I do was amazed at how Cooperative
it was how much people recognized the
urgency genuinely seem to want to work
together seem to
um
recognize that with social media they
didn't quite get things right and and
you know want to move quicker and better
so you have that on the positive side of
The Ledger on the negative side of The
Ledger it sort of feels like everybody
in Washington has their own ideas about
what to do and they're not necessarily
all coordinated and talking to each
other and I wouldn't say there's any one
clear answer that has emerged yet
um and so like there's a lot of
motion but whether that motion turns out
to be coherent I think is the question
there's one moment I liked in the Senate
proceedings which was a kind of
recognition of their own limitations I
can't remember who was that said it but
they said look we're not here to
legislate like the day-to-day the way I
were to repeat it is the Senate
shouldn't be there to make rules for GPT
5 as opposed to gpt4 the Senate should
be there to create an enduring agency
that can move with the flow and follow
all of the details and I think you know
some of them realize that they don't
want to be micromanaging the details of
AI development if they get it right they
will build some agency that is Nimble
enough fast enough to be able to deal
with things as they move yeah that that
the last thing you'd want is the Senate
have to check in any time is a new
development
they don't want that you don't want them
to do that right I mean with due respect
I mean some of the Senators are really
following what's going on like I saw
Senator Blumenthal on a call after the
um proceedings and he really understands
all of the issues he's following very
closely but you can't expect 100
monitors to all you know have their
fingers on on the pulse of AI they might
like right now because they're going to
make a first important decision but you
know certainly in the long term they
have so many other things to focus on
and so they shouldn't be micromanaging
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guests thank you